👏
skrattar du
fölora du
MANEEEEEEEEEEEN
YouTube's most respected show
Thank you guys for tuning in.
Now, will you accept this challenge?
By hitting the thumbs-up and the bell button.
You laugh.
You lose.
Let's frickin do this guys.
Together we can do it. Together, we are strong. DO NOT skrattar.  I'm looking at you.
*whispers* How you doin' babe? *fake croud laughing*
(the sports narrator narrates the sport in german)
Oh great
*loud voice over the sport narrator* SIX - NINE
*pewd quietly chuckles* (sports narrator still speaking german)
Why is this a meme like I see it everywhere.
It's not even- *laughing*
Alright! I gotta find the original.
He's like in a pool with an egg here...
(music: Low from Flo Rida can be heard)
Wait, is it real?
Wait, is it real? *chuckles (looks uncertain)*
Where's the original? I'm try-, cuz he's in a- he's a swimming pool.
Jacuzzi or something. Okay. It isn't real he just- *inaudible because he started the video*
(same song, high pitched) (''jeans,  boots with the FUR, the FUR...'''
*pewds humming/singing* now the whole club's looking at her...
*not singing, talking*  Nothing like a good old jacuzzi bath with your fellow AK.
*stars laughing and in high pitched voice* ha, he looks so dumb!
*genuine laughs*
Oh my god, I got a do, I got a do a video on my boy, my boy.
*says something inaudible*
*hold music, soft music*
(music ended abruptly.  There's a sound of movement then silence again)
Hey six - nine
(buzzer sound) six - nine (cocking gun sound)
(song: Education Connection Commercial Jingle)
This- *stops music* This meme really took off, huh ?
*sing-song tone* Who posted it first? that's right everybody I get extra meme points!
👏👏👏
I really would love to see some sort of meme currency.
If anyone can please invent a meme currency that puts a new- any meme...
It's like a stock, right? And you can invest in the meme stock. This, I know this is a billion dollar idea.
Cuz this is a rebound meme. Like this is an older meme coming back.
So let's say you had invested in this meme and then it takes off *👌clicks fingers* BAM
Millionaires.
(still the same jingle music)
(''...matched me with the right college for fr-'')
(F-R-E-E. that spells cr*ditr*port.com baby...)
(the interrupting song: credit report . com baby)
*softly* I don't know. I don't like this meme. Sorry.
(''that's a good painting you got there...)
(''...too bad it's the wroong one.'')
*unimpressed* I got it. It's obunga.
(''This is the right painting! You've got the wrong painting!'')
(''I don't know; they look exactly alike!'')
(''SILENCE fools!'') *pewds laughing*
(''It's gone long enough. This painting clearly (???)...'')
(''...and it must be destroyed.'') *pews laughs at that* (''No!no destroying that painting. That's a piece of history
(''No! No destroying that painting. That's a piece of history.'')
(''Come on, I painted this.'')
(''WHAT?'')
Oh no, why am I in there?
*they are litteraly ALL screaming*
(buzzer)
(All the Meeseeks from Rick and Morty keeps repeating ''him or that one there. He wrote me into this!'')
And, there can only be E okay?
There can only be E or B actually...now that I think about it.
You know what? Ignore me!
(''Imagine'')
*laughs*
Every fortnight thumbnail ever.
(''FBI coming in!'') (guy screams)
(''Yep'')
(''This is  a bucket'') *laughs*
No... not the bucket. Oh my god, so random! Whenever it's random, I just can't help myself.
Every (guy screaming) isn't it?
('' U - R - M - R - G - A - Y...)
(''If you look closer it will read you are Mr-'')
(''the only thing my mom used  to ever tell me was don't let people (distorted)grab my PlAyStAtI0n)'')
(''People will find a way'')  (''No!!'')
*chuckling*
God DAMMIT! Are you having fun watching this blank face then occasionally letting out a ha ha?
I hope you're being entertained as much as I am.
Come on! Give me something good. Come on!
(''...one goal...To wipe out half the universe.'')
(''If he gets all the Infinity stones...'')
((it's the 'Avengers Infinity War' trailer by the way))
(''Tell me his name again.'')
(BUZZ LIGHTYEAR!'')
I don't know. They're creative but they're not funny, okay.?
He's gonna grab an ak...
Oh there he is again! The 6-9-9 memes everybody. God dammit *laughs*
I don't even know why I laughed. Okay, and I actually didn't laugh. Hey...
I didn't laugh. *cocks gun* (buzzer)
Hey, it's a painting memeeverybody. It's gonna be obunga!
I guarantee you. There he is!
So beautiful. Oh my gAAAAAAAAA *laughs*
I would love to see a meme that is
just random memes that pretends that their memes from the future, because literally anything is just a meme these days.
You can't- you can't appoint us something be like 'no, that's ridiculous that can never be a meme'. Literally anything can be a meme.
Which is the beauty of meme everybody.
(''suspect is flying on foot'')
Of course! Of course.
(''Wake up lieutenant'' Connor's slap scene from veidogame Detroit Become Human = really loud edit)
(''It's me! Connor.'')
I need to play that stupid game. But AM I GONNA? ha ha
(trumpetman saying unimportant bullshit...which is already written on screen)
*pewds chuckles at this nonsensical speech*
I swear trump just read Starship Troopers and be like, yeah. Yep. It's time.
(''-to be the best pirate I have ever seen.'')
(''so it will seem.'')
pirate! uh-
*laughs*
(the Pirate of the Caribbean music really covers what they're saying)
(''PAY FOR MUS-'')  You cut before the best bit! the holbushshh, the hhijolsgdjvihrddllo (gibberish)
*laughing*
(''What did I do??'')
(''You know it's illegal to download copyrighted music! I'm taking you in!'')
(girl screams loudly)
I guess he's not that great of a pirate.
Hey, *cocks gun* Never illegally download!      (''now concentrate'')
Hey, it's another painting meme.
What is it going to be?
What are they gonna do? What they gonna do? What are they (gibberish) obunga. Obunga.
I got my bets on obunga.
Come on...come on.
My man, my man, come on. Come on fifty bucks!
Fifty bucks. Fifty bucks on obunga.
Five hundred. Five hundred thousand. Five millions. Obunga.
My man, - DAMN IT!! *laughs*
(''Oh my god'')
(song: Intro from Blend S anime)
SKRATTA DU. FÖLORA DU! MANNEEEEE...
*pewds immediatly laughed* yes!  oooooh (russian music in background)
(weeb song: Endless Tears - Maiko Nakamura ft. Cliff Edge... just look at pewds face!) Yea!
(''I've been watching gdq for two years now and today I just found out that my grandpa died two hours ago'' crowd applauses.
That was amazing. (sarcasm)
*chuckles*
There's nothing funny about dying in Mario Kart.
(same Japanese song as just before)
(''IF your name is Junior aaand you're really handsome, coooome on raise your haaand'')
Alright, I don't even know what to say. That was fantastic. Well done. All the links in the description everybody.
Did you skratta? Did you fölora? Let me know in the comments.
Leave a like if you skratta. Leave a like if you fölora. And as always...
(just a slight ringing...)
(nice soft percussions type of music)
(now it's chord instrument? the pitch goes downwards starting from higher pitched)
(really arcade game kind of music, neutral but sets the ambiance)
(weird twirling sound...a kind of flute? it's like someone washing a window!)
(violins, classical music since boss is defeated; a happy/light higher tone)
Personal note: please take subtitles seriously. It is suppose to depict at least the sounds/talking going on. Some people need them.
Also, Pewdiepie said previously that Animal Super Squad (ASS) is out on all consoles.